Yeah, yeah. You're gonna feast on this one.
Conceptuality is something other than itself.
There's been a change in the image of thought.
That's what it is, that's what it is.
The internal structure of book comedy.
As soon as an utterance slips from the mouth, it's divorced from the subject.
Thinking with, thinking, thinking with.
Um, no, I would do some Nietzsche.
I mean, partially, I mean, this sort of leads into how I wanted to start with Derrida,
which is just, I, you know, I think we should return to the pedagogical dimension of what
we're doing pretty frequently in the way that we kind of started with Hegel and even to a
sense like Deleuze and certainly like the Heidegger stuff is, you know, the amateur approach to
what, what we're doing here, like an amateur in the sense of, you know, cultivating it a
more of like toward the thing, that kind of intimacy, but you know, the, with Hegel, you
know, like none of us are Hegel experts, you know?
Um, and you know, like I wouldn't, um, say that any of us are Derrida experts, but that's
not what the closest, like John, you get to saying you're an expert in anything.
Right.
I'll tell you what, I feel it.
I have been feeling it lately.
It's just like, it's a weird feeling, but it's like, I read this stuff and I'm like, this
is just like reading a fucking magazine article.
Like this is easy.
Like I don't even understand anymore why someone would think, I mean, other than that, I remember
that, but I've been so immersed in it for three months now that I'm just like, I, this
is straightforward.
And, and, but that, that leads to an approach thing as we're talking about, uh, this Derrida
and especially for me, Plato's pharmacy, which, you know, I mean, like paling in comparison
to you, John, but I've, you know, I've read it a handful of times in grad school and since
then, and then I've sort of written around it and then now I've taught it three or four
times.
So I've like, you know, read it like, you know, probably getting close to double digits now
and written lectures and stuff on it.
And, um, you know, part of the question is just how do we do this thinking with thing
when the, the intimacy has already been kind of built?
Like I, you have to wonder, like, what are we doing?
Like, what is the sort of the pedagogical thing that we are working with here?
When we, you move from a text that you're not, you know, I don't think any of the stuff
we were reading for the first, first time, although I did it, the Dinkins, like the, uh, Heidegger,
I'd never read that before.
Um, but you know, we're sort of, you saw it like the pedagogy is more pronounced when
you're approaching something that you're less familiar with and it's about cultivating that
intimacy.
But how do you work the intimacy into something that's already so intimate?
It's very difficult to like tell it apart from yourself.
I don't know.
I mean, I, I feel like, I mean, what's happened for me in terms of the course of the, the
lectures on this, you know, writing the lectures, everybody, like, let me say it this
way.
I have not been in a loss for things to say like that.
It never once have I felt like, in fact, here's what I think.
And I was thinking this the other day of like, I could teach this exact same class with the
exact same series next spring and write totally different lectures.
Like, I mean, I just don't find, to me, it's just, it's just so infinitely generative of,
there are just so many lines, right?
That you can follow.
And it's like, so fine.
I follow, for instance, it's very clear the line that I take on the second half of Plato's
Pharmakon, which is the Hegel, right?
That like, why this is, I mean, it's obviously a response to what we've been doing for the
last two years.
Like, why he sees this as prior to oppositionality, right?
Like, and why that's important and whatever.
But like, that's by far not the only, like, there's, think of the things that I don't talk
about.
Like, the pharmakos, you know, the whole, you know, there's just like so many topical things
in there that I don't even touch on play, hardly at all, right?
Like, and so I just feel like there's just so many different lines in there.
I just also think that this is a fucking amazing essay.
Like, I mean, I don't think this about every essay that we've done this with.
But I, in reading this, I'm just like, there's so many different lines, strands, dimensions.
Because he's reading Plato, right?
He's reading the oeuvre of Plato.
So there's a massive amount of different stuff.
Like, the paternity thing, you know, like, I talk a little bit about it, but you could
just write on that.
Like, you could just follow that line.
Yeah.
What amazes me about this essay is that he's obviously deploying familiar conceptual architecture,
Derridean conceptual architecture, but it doesn't feel derivative or self-consuming of his
own work.
Like, the way that the pharmacon operates as kind of the movement of difference, it's still
useful to play it out through this example and through Plato, right?
So it's not the same as the Différance essay, you know, even though it's dealing with the
similar questions and how...
Conceptual stuff.
Exactly.
Yeah.
It seems important to me that that's, in that sense, that Différance is not, or Deconstruction
is not a method.
It's not in order to produce some kind of effect.
You know, it really does, it is closer to a kind of a close reading that has a kind of
courage to, you know, not presume that there's a transcendent, you know, architecture that's
keeping it all coherent, that you're just decoding, is actually to follow the way that
one line, you know, starts to get woven into another line.
And then the following of that line starts to mess with the tapestry at large.
And again, I think there's a kind of a courage and dedication to like having to stick with
all of those, like what happens, how do you follow a thread when the entire world is changing
around you as you are following that thread?
That, like, requires stamina.
And it's so obviously, go ahead, it's just so, it's so obviously not theory application
too, like it's not, it's not like he wrote Differance and then was like, all right, now
I'm going to interpret Plato through the lens of Differance.
It's that Plato happens to articulate some of the dynamics of Differance, but in productive
and interesting ways.
It's just, it's, it's, it's weird that there's, there's, there's parallels between the concepts
and the works, but it still is enlivened through that, that way of reading, you know, I don't
know, it just, it's surprising to me that he's able to, you know, accumulate and generate
that kind of diversity of thinking, even when the conceptual stuff is, is pretty similar.
But, and I'll tell you just from my experience, I mean, it's, it's just kind of astonishing.
Like, I, at this point in the semester, I was in this pretty regular rhythm, which is that
I would read on Saturday and Sunday, we're doing my annotations and marginalia, and then
on Monday I would sit down and it would took me eight hours, but I just go through and literally
transcribe what I'd underlined in my marginalia.
That's all I would do is I'm just copying his words.
And in the course of doing that, every single time, lines would emerge and things that I
was like, oh, I want to see how this connects to this thing.
And like, essay topics would emerge.
And then on Tuesday I would actually write the lecture, you know, that had emerged out
of simply copying him, you know, copying the things that he's saying.
And, and that's the point where I'm like, I really do think, no joke, like you could just
do that indefinitely.
Like you could really write that essay indefinitely because you just hook it to something else.
And like, well, how does this play out in Aristotle or how does this play out?
You know, you could just continue hooking those lines because lines aren't self-identical,
right?
As you said, like you're following one line and then you realize you're smack dab in the
middle of another and you've got to backtrack to get to that, you know.
But to Nate's point, it's, it's a bit, it's not that theory application.
Be like, and now we will look at how difference works in Aristotle.
Like there would have to be, you know, you would have to follow the particular line that
takes you to a particular part of Aristotle and then starts, then everything that you've
been kind of on weaving and in Plato starts to then bear on the, the Aristotelian lines.
And by the way, there are like 14 other ways of 14 other threads that you could have followed
over to Aristotle and, you know, another 32 styles that would have taken you over there
and started messing with Aristotle very differently.
So like when you say you could write on it indefinitely, you know, that's not an exaggeration
at all.
It's not, it's not like, I mean, for instance, here's, here's one of the, I mean, I just remember
this when I was writing the lecture that I think I mentioned, but I don't talk about
is the Korah stuff, right?
In the, from the Timaeus, right?
That's, that's huge.
Like there's a whole cosmology, you know, in form content relations that's built into that,
to that problem.
And it's just like, you know, I mean, you could write a book on that, I mean, that alone.
And it's, so there's just so much that's suggestive and so much, again, it's not even
that this is a particularly great essay, it's just the, the way that it works and what it
does to expand the boundaries of texts, right?
Like, I mean, that's, that's to me, you know, I made a big deal of that in the lectures of
like the, and that was big for me that we talked about last time of, of like the Egyptian
thing, the Egyptian mythology, which is a chunk that I had never paid any attention
to, you know, I'd always just kind of skimmed it and whatever, there's this Egyptian mythology,
but then I realized, oh, I see what he's doing here.
And it changed everything.
It's like, are we in or outside Plato's texts when we're talking about the Egyptian version
of the mythology?
Because the answer's, the answer's not easy.
Well, I mean, the answer is like the, the, the, the question doesn't make sense.
What do you mean by in or, in or out here?
I was just going to say that, you know, just like hearing the range of things that you
just talked about, like, wow, the scope of this essay is really immense.
And I don't think that that's like actually the, the right word of even talking about it
because it's not, you know, it's not trying to contain anything.
It doesn't have any scope whatsoever.
It doesn't have a surface area, right?
Like in thinking about it as a, as a web, it only has intersecting lines.
There is no, it has no domain.
It has no boundary.
It has no territory, right?
That, that, that's, I think that's an important thing that I, I mean, just, you know, to bring
it back to the pedagogy thing and also to introduce a certain kind of ethics that I think that
has been in an important part of the Thinking With operation is that to declare a,
Hey, Larissa, Larissa just wanted to wave in Heidi, Larissa.
She says hi.
To declare like my book is about X, Y, or Z to say that like, this is the terrain that
I'm going to deal with.
And then this is the terrain that I'm not going to deal with.
Even when you make what has become the perfunctory move of like, it's just one, you know, like,
like take at it.
And I'm obviously not like the authority on it, but you're still making an authoritative
claim.
Like this is the terrain that I have relative mastery over.
This is the terrain that more or less is set outside of it.
And that's just like a fundamentally different orientation to the, like, I follow a thread
and then follow where that thread bumps into another thread and it doesn't create a terrain.
You know, this is like be a way in which to like, actually, I think this thread should
be bumping us into that language of territorialization and de-territorialization is I think would
force it to kind of be rethought, not in terms of boundaries, or at least force us to re-approach
that boundary making operation.
And that's where the question that you raised earlier about the expertise and it's, and what
that happens, what happens to the pedagogical element of like our interaction in the podcast
thing is like, I actually haven't found that it's been a problem, right?
Like at all.
In fact, if anything, it's just like, no, I have more facility with different kinds of
lines.
And so it's like, it's actually sort of more generative in the sense of like, I feel maybe
less like an expert in the sense of a mastery thing.
In fact, I wrote the most recent, one of the most recent lectures is on the difference
between what I'm calling understanding and following.
Understanding, which is that kind of topological, like, you know, top-down sort of viewpoint,
the totalizing, whereas following, and in that sense, it's like the following is infinite.
I mean, it is just, you know, because also, as we know, following is not just something
that's there that you're coming after, right?
You're also generating the line as you are following the line.
So yeah, like, I haven't found at all that the sense that, like, I'm developing a mastery
of, and let's be clear, I'm developing a mastery of Derrida from 1967 to 1972, right?
Like, really, no joke, right?
It's like, Derrida on the issue of writing over a five-year span is the stuff that I feel
like I'm an expert.
Like, there's so much other stuff that I haven't even touched on, you know?
And so, therefore, like, it's such a minimal, but even within that kind of confines of expertise,
like, I still, I feel, it's not that I don't understand it, it's that that doesn't matter,
right?
Like, it's just, like, yeah, I could tell you the argument of any particular thing, but
who cares?
It's like, the more interesting thing is, what are the 18 different lines that that hooks
into that allow you to produce other things, you know?
Yeah, which, I mean, resonates with his process, I'm sure.
Like, the way you're talking about how you generate your lecture is sort of a sampling and
following approach, where you take chunks and then follow the line where it takes you.
You have to think that he's doing a similar thing with a lot of his essays, because you
can see where the thinking takes him, and he doesn't edit that out.
He leaves in the process, where he's like, oh, and this chunk takes me here, even when
they're, like...
It's paratactic rather than hypotactic.
Exactly.
Absolutely.
Even when there's asides, like, he will leave the aside in there, follow it through, and
then keep writing.
So, I...
And also, curiously enough, the aside will end up, like, hooking back into something...
Yeah.
...that turns out not to have been an aside, right?
That's the amazing thing to me.
But that approach, that sampling approach, as opposed to, like you said, the understanding,
approach, where you'd attempt to comprehend the text in its entirety, is so useful, even
for undergrad students.
If you can relay that principle, like, because it's liberating, where you can say, just take
a chunk and key into it.
Latch onto something that kind of pulls you into the text, and then run with that.
Right.
You don't have to worry about fully comprehending all of it.
Mastery of the total disco.
That's what I've been using pedagogically for the grad students.
And it seems like...
I mean, I'm going to ask them tonight, but it seems like it's working, like...
Because you're right, it's liberate.
It's like, oh my gosh, it's okay that I don't understand these three pages, right?
Because I hooked into something, and I see it occur somewhere else, and I want to try
to figure out how to put...
But, like, especially with reading Derrida, isn't that all of our experiences when we initially
read Derrida?
It's like, oh, I feel like I understand these two sentences, but then I'm lost for two pages,
and then I get another couple sentences, you know?
But, like, to bring it back to the pedagogical ethical orientation, too, is it makes me think,
you know, you're making the distinction between following and understanding, and as an aside,
that maybe it will turn out to be an aside, maybe it will bring us back to something central,
as I always think of Gadamer's language on understanding as an understand, not transcendent,
not over, but, like, a sort of an orientation, or, like, a familiarity within a space or a
ground, but set that to the aside for a second, is that, and focus on the following side of
it, is that hypotaxis is not capable of following, right?
That parataxis is the movement that at least has a greater affinity for the possibility
of following, because, you know, it creates the possibility of, you know, seeing where
one thread runs para to, or buts into, or juxtaposes to, you know, another thread, and
then, you know, the specific place where one thread runs into another thread, following that
meticulously.
But hypotaxis is, I mean, I think that you talk about this in the Limited Ink lecture
that you wrote, which I did read, and it's sort of, like, it almost has to begin from
a paratactical, like, a space where there's just, like, a series of possible juxtapositions,
associations, and then it maps on a certain number of logic-making devices that, all right,
here are two things that are related, and now the hypotactical link forces the direction,
like, it subordinates one to the other.
This one is for the sake of this first one, and, you know, it is reduced to the tropological
function of evidence or of, you know, counter...
Justification for your claim.
Justification.
Whatever it is, which, like, it's a fundamentally limiting device that tries to corral, you know,
the potentiality of that new connection.
And as you point out, like, that's oftentimes the case.
That's valuable.
That's sort of, like, because, you know, you have to be able to reduce the number of possible
moves at most times in order to, like, live in the world in any kind of predictable, you
know, way, but it doesn't seem, it does seem to be problematic for a certain sense of thinking,
which, like, which we're like, okay, no, now that I've developed a certain stability where
I don't think I'm going to die if I open up the possibilities of these connections, I
can sort of, like, create this small little space, like, all right, what are the other
possible lines?
How do I release it from a certain hypotoxus?
Yeah.
I mean, one of the, like, the, one of the notions that, um, that Derrida is talking about is
that, like, writing, you know, obviously is kind of a threat.
Writing in that, uh, kind of deconstructive sense is a threat against the Socratic notion
of, like, knowledge and mastery.
And what's interesting about the way we're talking is that the, obviously, the writing
that Derrida is after and that he tries to cultivate and that we also try to emulate or
imitate, that is precisely the, the target or the threat, um, that, that Plato's text attempts
to extinguish or, you know, secure, um, through dialectics, right?
So, like, the stuff that we see as productive, like, where we're just following threads and
opening ourselves up to otherness, you know, the otherness of the text or the otherness of
different threads of thinking, that's precisely what he's trying to tame and master, uh, through,
like, a dialectical process.
But don't you, don't you think, like, I, I, I agree with that in terms of that baseline
assumption, but it, it, the, the thing that springs to mind as you say that is, like, all
of composition seems to be organized hypotactically.
Like, it seems to be platonic in its inheritance, right?
Like, that it's not training people.
I mean, I don't want to exaggerate that too much.
There certainly are elements, uh, within composition that are more free writing-ish, you know, uh,
the, the dimensions of it, expressivist, um, so it can't, I mean, although that just links
it to the self and, you know, there's not a lot of following going on there.
Uh, but, but nevertheless, it's like, you know, just think of how we teach essays and what are
the five paragraph theme in the current traditional version, but even the process models are still
always thought hypotactically and how, how much it would shift if you said, let's start
from a paratactic, uh, way of thinking about teaching writing.
Like, that would, I just think, and again, I also, like what Nathaniel said, to me, hypotaxis
ends up having to be a form of parataxis.
Like, it just has to be, it has to work that way.
Um, and so through following, you create structure and organization.
Like, that's just how it goes.
And you've already implicitly been employing some kind of structure and organization in
your active following anyway, right?
Like, so, so I get that they're not simply opposed, but if we could provisionally and
heuristically say, what would a composition classroom look like in which writing was thought
paratactically as a following of one's and the other's thinking?
I just think my, my intuition is to say it would look wildly different than anything that
I hear of as kind of composition pedagogy usually.
Well, can I interest you in a brochure for the Mark St. Vincent's, um, writing program?
You have six courses and you'll have a minor and you will learn to use writing as a method
of paratactical thinking.
Well, as I was editing some of the podcasts, Nathaniel, you were talking about one of your
assignments.
I think it was, uh, it was like an exploratory essay or invention draft.
Yeah.
Invention draft.
And that to me kind of seemed like it was, uh, it resonated with what you're just talking
about, John, where you're the, you know, you're explicitly telling them not to, to formulate
it in the terms of like traditional argument.
We don't want a thesis statement.
Right.
No thesis statement, but it's, but that doesn't mean that there isn't like a reason or a rhyme
why you, why you go from one thing to another.
Right.
There's just like, you've multiplied the reasons and rhymes, how you can go from one thing to
another.
And then what that produces as a chaotic, you know, nuts and mass, but also a really rich
terrain from which to start to build.
And so like, you know, I, I teach, like I basically to use this terminology, you know,
most of my class is focused on creating paratactical generation of material.
And then when you have an overabundance of that to start thinking about the hypotactical
possibilities that it affords.
Yeah.
Which is, you know, keep in mind, I kept that plural, right.
Uh, it's, um, that, you know, it's not like then make it hypotactic according to this line
of this is still part of that inventive possibility.
Right.
Yeah.
Well, and I, I feel like that's actually, that's not a totally non-traditional way of teaching
composition.
I mean, that's at least the way I try to approach it.
Like, we're like, you ask them to find the argument, not to start with it.
Right.
I mean, like you don't like, so if you're starting hierarchically, you're going to inherently
limit the possibilities of your essay.
But if you, if you follow lines and follow threads, you will find the argument, even if
it's implicit at first, or even if it's chaotic or untethered, because literally every statement,
every inclination has an argument within it.
Like just saying I'm hungry is an argument.
Just like, even just like desires and impulses have little weird micro arguments, um, that
you can kind of unravel.
I would say they can be configured as arguments for sure.
Exactly.
Right.
Yeah.
That's how I think of it too.
Right.
Yeah.
I'm not, I'm not, I'm not, everything's an argument.
But everything can be configured as an argument.
Yeah.
Everything can be, but that's the hypotacticizing move, right?
Like is to transform it into an argument.
To say everything is an argument is to naturalize hypotaxis, right?
Right.
That's right.
Yeah.
Right.
Um, but, but, but everything can be argumentized.
Like I, I, I have no problem with that, but that, like, I just want to hang out.
So, but, but for instance, I think of the way, and maybe it's just me, but like, I think
of the way that I used to teach sort of critical reading and I really did, it was like, you've
got to figure out the argument first and then figure out what the reasons are.
Like, I was beginning from a hypotaxis as opposed to like with teaching Derrida and it's partly
because of how difficult Derrida is to read and the non-familiarity that the grad students
have with it.
I'm like, don't try to understand the argument.
Like, really just don't.
I mean, it's, it's, you'll be frustrated if you do. Instead, just hook into a point he
makes and, and think through it and like, see if it comes up again.
You know, that kind of, that's a different thing in terms of literally like how I'm teaching
them to read these texts.
And it's, I, I just find, in fact, that's actually what I have been doing over 25 years
of reading that text, right?
It's like just piecing it together.
Now, what has happened is I've done it so much and I've been so immersed in it for a
while that now I feel like, ah, I can step back and see how the Egyptian stuff connects
to this, you know, mythos logos distinction in antiquity.
But I couldn't do that for a really, really long time.
Like it took a shit ton of, you know, these just sort of following particular lines and
hooking in and, and being okay with not hooking in before I could do that.
But that, that sampling approach can give you a dissertation.
I mean, what do you think I did with Hegel?
You think I tried to comprehend the entirety of Hegel's oeuvre?
No, because that would be a ridiculous thing to impose upon yourself.
I didn't even try to read.
I mean, I read most of it, but I didn't try to interpret or include all of the Phenomenology
even into the, because there's just too much there that's not relevant to my project, right?
I mean, like I wasn't putting the religion stuff or even most of the ethic stuff.
So like, if you can, which, which I did, like key in on sections, just sections of the text and elaborate on them and, and forge connections between, you know, Hegel and contemporary theory.
Like that was enough for me to write nearly like, you know, 200 some odd pages just on that shit.
And it was never formed with that hypotactic, like, okay, now that I've mastered Hegel, I can write about him, like kind of approach, you know?
And I actually don't think, I mean, I actually don't think, because the usual way of thinking that experience, I think would be like, yes, but you have a baseline expertise, familiarity in reading, which allows you to read that way.
And I'm like, I actually am not, I just don't believe that.
Like, I actually just believe this actually genuinely could be a really great way to teach 18-year-old writers, like, you know, really, like, you don't have to understand the argument.
That's not what we're starting with, right?
And that's not even the telos necessarily.
It's like, just follow lines of thinking, follow the points.
What is the point that he's making and why is he making that?
Like, just start with that.
Right, right.
I mean, I guess the wall that you might occasionally hit with 18-year-olds is that a lot of them just either are not curious about their own thinking or about other people's thinking, or they don't know how to, like, express that curiosity through writing.
That's true.
They might be able to do it through other mediums, but, like, because writing is such a difficult enterprise, at least at that age or initially for some people, like, even if you give them the out or the in of, like, hey, let's make this exploratory.
Let's follow these threads.
It could still be paralyzing for a certain percentage of them, you know, where they're like, I don't.
I get that, because I always felt, I mean, for me, I always felt like the versions of free writing that I encountered, I hated, like, if it's just sit down and generate, I'm like, I, what, where is that?
From where?
Whereas, for instance, if I, in the case of Derrida or whatever, like, if I'm working with someone else's words, it's way easier, right?
Like, it's just like, okay, so here's a sentence.
I just literally transcribed the sentence.
Now, what the fuck does that sentence say, right?
Like, you know, I mean, really, and it's just way easier for me to, like, okay, I understand the project of trying to figure out what the hell he just said in that sentence and why he would say that and what implications it has.
That makes sense to me, as opposed to, oh, no, just right, like, why?
From what, with what, right?
And that risks so much, sort of, just like, I mean, emotivism or subjectivism.
And, you know, I imagine, like, certain versions of the bricolage, the flâneur, that's just sort of like a little bit of this and a little bit of that.
And then, you know, you just, you create a random series of associations.
And, yes, it will be inventive, but, like, it lacks rigor.
It lacks, it doesn't, like, you know, I mean, I think about the language of, like, the scene doesn't necessarily hold.
Just because you throw two things at each other doesn't mean that they stick without figuring out the particular places to stitch.
And, you know, I would just, I would say, like, I imagine, as Nate's working through the parts of the Phenomenology, is that you're, like, you don't just randomly have it on, you know, this or that section.
It's like, you know, working through one part of it leads you to another part of it.
And, you know, like, and you don't pay attention to a certain part of it because, like, the threads don't stick, right?
But then you get to the part that does stick, and then you start, like, really carefully working through it.
And then that leads you to the next one.
And it kind of, like, the way that you've worked it.
And the truth is, you read it again in a year where you're working on a, you know, you're done with your dissertation, you're working on some other kind of essay, and you'd be like, oh, my God, how did I ignore all this religion stuff?
Like, this is so absolutely central to the whole thing, right?
Yeah.
But that is, like, this is how we should teach 18-year-olds.
But that, I mean, like, look, I don't teach thesis statements to my 18-year-olds, you know?
I mean, like, I do, though, like, I use the Bartholomae book and, you know, the ways of reading, and, you know, it's like the, like, I teach Foucault and stuff like that.
And, you know, like, I do not begin hypotactically at all.
In fact, I kind of, like, give the argument maybe three or four weeks into it just as a quick aside.
I'm like, oh.
But, like, in a way that, like, that actually kind of makes sense now in a way that, like, if you were to give me that argument up front, it would have been just as much gibberish as everything else would have been gibberish.
And, you know, starting with is, like, like, I mean, the problem with the free riding is, like, how do you, you don't have, you don't know how to ride the bicycle yet.
So, it's slowing down, like, how do you take the sentence and then slow it down and problematize it or question it or, like, meditate on it for a little bit so that it can open itself up and lead you to another sentence or another passage.
And, like, just slowing down the movement of how to think one's way from passage to another passage to another passage is, like, I think both a really valuable way of learning to read but also an incredibly valuable way of learning to write as well.
Because it's the, for me, it's the writing on it that creates those, those linkages.
So, I mean, importantly, in that version, there are still sort of normative guardrails, right?
Like, it's not like, I mean, that's to me, and again, I also think that the version of free riding we're probably talking about is probably a dumb version of free, like, I believe that there's a more interesting version.
I just don't know it.
I mean, whatever, this is what I was told to do when I was 17 years old or something.
But, like, what, you know, what you're saying, it's, like, it's not about saying just do whatever feels right.
It's, like, it's not that.
It's, like, no, do a particular exercise, which is select something that interests you and figure out what it means and figure out its significance and figure out its relevance.
Like, in other words, it's solve a mystery kind of question.
And a mystery that you pick, which is, like, whatever.
Pick a sentence, pick a paragraph, pick whatever.
Like, something that has hooked you, that made you go, huh.
You know, and start there, right?
Like, that's just.
Well, I begin effectively, you know.
It's, like, all right, pick the thing.
You know, you don't have to pick the right thing.
There's not the right passage to begin with.
No, there's no right.
Right.
But choose the thing that irked you or confused you or frustrated you or intrigued you or sparked your curiosity.
Whatever it is, like, whatever that emotive reason is, like, up, like, in a sentence or two.
Like, this intrigued me or irked me because, and then here's a particular thing about it that did this.
And here's how I'm going to try to, like, think through what about it is doing this thing.
And then once you have that machinery running, it takes you to another passage.
And then you don't need the emotive thing anymore.
Because the first line is opening up the second passage, which opens up the third, which opens up the fourth, as long as you do the work of the connecting.
And that, to me, is also an infinitely generative machine.
You know, like, I say you could literally follow this process and write forever.
But I'm asking you to do it in, you know, 800 words.
So stop at 800 words, right, whatever cycle you head to.
I mean, it's funny because, I mean, honestly, like, when I undertook to teach this class, I limited, just because Derrida is so massive, I limited it to Derrida on writing as the sort of thematic, you know, focal point.
But I always thought it was going to be, like, just a philosophy class on Derrida on writing that, of course, had theory implications for the field of composition studies.
But what has actually become, it is a lot of that, but what it has also become is a fucking graduate level composition class, right?
Like, it really, like, and a pedagogy class for me of, like, well, let's try this.
Let's see, like, for next week, you know, let's all do this sort of writing experiment and see what happens.
And for the week after, we'll do that.
It's really become a composition class without, you know, we are, I am acting as a writing instructor in the most conventional sense.
Now, what we're writing about is Derrida, so it's very specific and located.
But, like, man, it's just, I didn't expect that to be the case at all.
And yet, it has happened that way.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Yeah, I mean, I feel like also, like, in terms of getting over the hump where writing becomes enjoyable, which I think is sometimes the wall for even graduate students, where it's seen as this task that they have to do, right?
Even if it's the thing that they want to have their career be based on.
Like, it's anxiety-inducing and it's seen as they still sort of inherit all that traditional stuff where you're supposed to exhibit mastery, etc.
Like, to think of writing or to be able to do it as a creative process, I think is a real challenge for a lot of students.
And I, but I do, I really love the metaphor of, like, sampling and trying to employ that as a kind of method or orientation.
Because I do that in a bunch of different milieus.
Like, with music, obviously, sampling, that would be the term where it's most typically employed.
Where you take something, like, a sample from an old 70s hit or something obscure and you put it into another context and you make it function differently.
You put it under a hip-hop beat or something, right?
So you transport it into maybe a current context and reformulate it that way.
And you can do the exact same thing with Foucault or Hegel or whoever.
So you can, like, key into disciplinary power and see how, why is that still relevant for the university context, for society writ large, you know?
So you can do that kind of creative work.
It's just, it's difficult to get into that disposition, I feel like, for...
So this is, like, the hinge on which I, like, I'm sometimes I'm, like, totally with it and then sometimes I'm, like, eh.
And when you were describing it on the musical side, I was totally with it.
Because, I mean, because it's, like, you take the sample and then you put it in a new context.
And then, as you said, you have to make it, right?
You have to remake it within that context and remake the context around it.
You have to allow it to sort of, like, do its difference to the thing, right?
Right.
And that's, like, and I think you could do the same thing with, you know, inserting part of Foucault into something else and then treat Foucault as a kind of antigen that starts working through the new body that you've placed it into.
But it was just, like, and I don't think this is what you were getting after, but part of the imagery that you were using was more, like, how is Foucault still relevant to, you know, the university, you know, education complex?
And just that language made me think more of that transcendental relationship was, like, I will take Foucault as a lens and then this coherent thing called Foucault will, you know, provide a particular window or vision of the university lens, right?
Which, again, is going to introduce, like, the problems of masteries, like, how do I contain Foucault, turn it into a lens, be able to then methodologically use it to reveal this thing called the university, which, you know, what am I going to create the boundaries on, what am I going to focus on?
But you used to start, like, but I like the language of sampling more there.
Like, how do I take, slice out this, like, think about it more biological, slice out this, like, do a biopsy of Foucault, insert it in this new body, and then allow it to start to live in this new body and then see what it starts to do.
So one of the things this makes me think of is that what my undergrad sci-fi, which I told you is a non-majors class, and it's kind of a blow-off class, right?
It's just sort of, like, we watch movies and talk about them.
But the times when it works the best, and I've tried, I mean, I've tried to formalize it a little bit, but, like, it's not like you have to have an understanding of the movie that we watched.
Like, pick a fucking scene that you thought something interesting happened in, and then connect it in some way, like, why do you think it's interesting?
Like, oh, because that's a lot like circumstances today that are, and that's, it's the same kind of move.
Like, you're just, say, you're hooking into a moment without necessarily any kind of global understanding of the plot, the characters, and all that sort of shit.
Hooking into a moment and then connecting it to whether it's a situation in your life or in popular culture or whatever else.
And it's so generative, like, they, they, when you can get them to do that, and to, if you can get them to sort of say, I'm not asking you to make an argument about the matrix.
I'm not asking you to form some judgment or to do a reading of the matrix.
I'm asking you to, like, find a moment in the matrix that hooks you for, oftentimes, for reasons, like, I don't really know, but that seemed really cool.
So, like, I want to think about that.
And then we start talking about it, and they're like, oh, that reminds me of this other thing.
And it's the same kind of, now, that's video, right?
That's movies.
It doesn't have, and I say that partly because it doesn't have to be Derrida, right?
It's just sort of, so there's a different way of approaching even movies, which is, hypotactically, like, what is your, what is your thesis about the matrix, right?
Like, and that's, that is the thing that I feel like they find debilitating, because they're like, I don't know.
I don't know what to think.
That's a big, that's a lot of stuff.
I don't really, whatever.
It was boring, you know?
But if you, if you.
Nobody says that about the matrix.
But if you limit it, right?
If you say, like, look, you don't have to have an opinion or something about the matrix.
Just, like, what was something in the movie that made you go, like, huh?
Or, like, eh, whatever.
Like, to have some kind of response to, and then let's play out.
And talk it through.
What was that?
Yeah, and then, and it creates, and I'm like, you know, that's critical thinking.
Like, what we just did was we used whatever the text was, the matrix, whatever, to sort of think about whatever else.
Like, the Will Smith slap.
It's a catalyst.
Yeah, it doesn't, it doesn't matter.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, I mean.
But speaking of, speaking of the Will Smith slap, like, I mean, I just, I just threw that out there.
But, like, that was one of the things.
I had this, I had a, I hope it's going to turn into, like, a watershed life moment for me in response to that.
Insofar as I got, I mean, I didn't watch it and didn't know about it.
And I got my, like, sort of news updates.
And then the next day I went on social media and, like, everyone had opinions.
So what was it?
Will Smith slapped Chris Rock?
Slapped Chris Rock at the Oscars, yeah.
Like, as a, like, staged thing?
No.
Well, but that's one of the, that's one of the questions.
It doesn't seem like it.
But whatever.
Like, everybody had.
Like, did Chris Rock seem pissed about it?
But, like, hold on, let me get to, just shut up.
Okay, I'm sorry.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let me get to the fucking point.
The point was, you, yes, I get that you are in fucking Canada, so they don't have popular culture there.
But everyone I knew in the States, like, had opinions, right?
And all the opinions, what the opinions were, were, like, different ways of contextualizing it.
Which is, it's an issue of race.
It's an issue of masculinity.
It's an issue of mental illness.
It's an issue, like, it's an issue of stage versus, you know, artifice versus reality.
Like, so there were all these different contextualizations which were vying for.
Because we all agreed on the act, right?
Like, the text was, like, there.
And so you just had all of these different people contextualizing in different ways
and having sort of strong opinions about their way of contextualizing it.
And for whatever reason, I mean, I read through a lot of these things.
And I was just like, I have no opinion about this.
Like, and not because I think it's unimportant.
That would be an opinion, right?
Like, or I was just like, I have no opinion.
And my God, I don't need to.
It was this glorious moment where, for the first time, I was like, I don't have to have an opinion about this.
I don't have to try to come up with some pithy new angle that the other people haven't had or a way of summing up, like, the underlying logic of people's angles.
I was like, I see what's going on.
Like, I feel like I get what's going on, which is different attempts to contextualize, all of which are claiming that theirs is the right way, right?
And I don't have an investment.
I don't disinvest either.
I don't think it's a foolish thing to do.
I don't think it's stupid.
I just, like, it was this great, like, for the first time on a, like, social, popular culture thing, I was just, like, I felt like an observer.
Like, I was distant from it.
But also, like, in a kind of, like, oh, look at the sweet little life forms, like, doing their contextualizations and being invested.
Like, you know.
Domesticating the thing, right?
Yeah.
But it was also, it was great.
I'm like, of course, what else can you do, right?
Like, if you're going to intervene, all you can do is try to contextualize it and fight against the other contextualizations or come up with a meta context or whatever else.
And, again, every, this had nothing to do with the actual event because whatever.
But I just, it was this wonderful relation where I'm like, I want to live like this.
I want to live in this space where I don't have to have opinions about it.
I don't feel the internal need to have an opinion about something.
It's like.
There's that Bo Burnham sketch on that, right?
Yeah.
Like, what if?
What's that?
After one fucking second in the Bo Burnham sketch.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh, yeah.
I hadn't even thought of that.
I'm like, but that, maybe that's what it was.
I experienced my one second where I didn't have to have an opinion on a cultural event.
You know, I mean, I could have.
I could have intervened, like, you know, but I was just like, gosh, I don't really feel like doing that.
And, yeah, I'm in favor of what everyone is doing.
I'm not, you know.
You know who really doesn't have an opinion about this is Nathaniel because he has no idea what happened.
He's like, did Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson punch Jada Pinkett Smith?
Like, what happened?
Yeah.
No, like, I mean, because I, you know, like, on the places I do my reading, like, I saw headlines on it and they were all takes on the thing.
I'm like, I didn't watch the Oscars.
I don't know what actually happened and I don't really feel like reading takes on it.
But, yeah.
I wish this could be released, like, tomorrow because then this conversation would be relevant.
I don't know if it's going to be relevant in July or next year, next March when the season's released.
Like, who cares?
Well, look, it'll be irrelevant in a week, right?
Yeah, it already is almost.
But that's okay.
I mean, that's okay.
That's just how.
Yeah.
That's how, that's what our culture is, right?
Like, that's one aspect of our culture is everyone's going to have their hot takes on this thing.
And, again, the different contextualizations, that's what I mean is I was just like, oh, look, here is the social at work.
I saw it and I found it pretty profoundly disturbing, like, just the entire situation and scene and how it unfolded.
And then his speech, like, ten minutes after the slap was really unnerving.
It just seemed like we were witnessing a meltdown, you know, kind of like a Kanye-style meltdown,
like, where it's just incoherence and, like, crazy narcissism.
Like, right, just sort of, so I don't know.
I don't have any, like, race or gender or, you know, overarching arguments about the piece.
I just found myself, like, really kind of, it was upsetting to see the act and then to see everyone applaud him.
It was just really weird.
But they applauded him?
Did Chris Rock say something that everybody thought was like?
Yeah, Chris Rock made a joke about Jada Pinkett Smith having no hair.
He said her G.I. Jane look.
But she apparently publicly has, has publicly said she has alopecia.
Right.
And so Will Smith walked up on the stage and slapped him.
And then as he walked away.
Oh, he wasn't co-hosting?
No, no, no.
He walked up onto the stage in the front row and slapped him and said, keep my wife's name out your mouth.
Out your fucking mouth.
And he said it twice and he was not, it was not a bit.
Like, he was furious.
Like, full of rage.
Whether it was a bit or not, that's, again, that's one of the questions.
But, you know.
And then he, ten minutes later, won the Best Actor award and apparently, like, apologized for his actions or whatever.
Sort of.
I mean, he's talked about being a vessel for God's love.
And so, yeah, it was a lot of that.
Scientology speak.
I don't know.
Yeah.
It was really unhinged, really, is all it was.
It wasn't a bit.
I'll go ahead and I'll have that take.
A hundred percent was not a bit.
It was not orchestrated by, I mean, granted, it gave the Oscars a lot more viewers than they've had in recent years.
So, he probably did them a favor, but it was not an orchestrated segment.
Yeah.
Anyway, I hope, you know, it's also just, it's also just two billionaires, like, having a disagreement.
So, who gives a fuck?
Yeah, that's part of it, too.
But I definitely, I mean, at least, you know, in terms of talking about Derrida and signature event context specifically, it was just such a striking moment because everyone agrees on the text.
Yeah.
And all the conversation, all of it, 100 percent was just, it should be viewed through this context.
It should be viewed through this context.
It was just, like, differential attempts to say, no, no, no.
You people who are talking about that issue, you're not talking about the mental illness issue.
Or you people talking about mental illness, you're not dealing with the race issue.
Or some conjunction of race and fame and mental illness.
You know, whatever.
Like, it was always, like, this is the proper way.
It was just, like, such an exercise in watching everyone contextualize as a means of determining the truth.
Right?
Like, as a way of eliminating the other perspectives.
You know, it was, that's why it was just fun.
I mean, I, honestly, I just felt like I was watching the kind of video game of, like, I can see all of the different, you know.
And these are friends of mine.
Lots of people who have whatever.
They're sort of strong opinions.
And, of course, all the people that I know, they are the socially righteous ones, which nauseates me.
You know?
Yeah.
You know, I mean, there's always that tone in my friend's posts of, like, well, the thing that's being left out of this conversation is the morally righteous thing.
Because you're not thinking about the poor woman or whatever.
Right?
Whatever.
Like, I don't care about any of these people.
Yeah, they're all too famous and too successful to really deserve any pity or empathy.
But they're not people.
No, they're not.
Like, they are different types of roles.
And that's fine.
But they're also literally not human beings at that level.
Like, you graduate.
When you achieve that kind of, like, stratospheric success, you're no longer a human.
You know?
Like, Will Smith is not a person.
He's a famous alien.
Yeah.
What was that movie he did where he was the angry alien?
I can't remember the name of it.
Well, the joke would have worked if I'd come up with that.
Sucks, but he can't remember the name.
But, yeah.
So, I mean, it was just, like, I will probably use it tonight in the Daredevil class to be like, okay, here's context, right?
Like, here's how context works.
And, again, in a way in which no one, I mean, for me at least, no one is saying, hey, no one is explicitly saying, your contextualization is too limited.
My contextualization is more vast.
Like, they weren't saying it that clearly, right?
But that's what was happening in every sort of, every take and everyone being done righteously.
Like, I'm the one who's getting, I'm just like, man, all, I mean, all of this just fills me with, like, this is, again, it's not even gross or bad.
It's just, like, this is society.
Like, this is what culture is, is people contextualizing stuff based on their own, again, it's not just their own causes.
It's not that it's not there.
It's just based on a particular limited perspective and insisting that that's the perspective, right?
Like, I mean, and, again, I don't know.
The thing that was nice for me was I don't know which one is right and I don't even care.
Like, I don't care to invest myself to figure out, like, how much would I weigh?
Yeah.
Right.
Like, how much would I weigh the race issue versus the mental illness issue versus the masculinity issue?
You know what I mean?
Like, I don't even care to try to weigh those things.
It's just, like, this isn't something that happened.
What I do see just in the responses is just, like, how therapeutic that activity is, like, with the kind of coping mechanism that it is.
Is that, like, here, you know, the way that you described it, Nate, is this, like, this breach, this, like, unsettling, just, like, uncomforting thing.
And, you know, even when I contextualize it within, like, a very sort of, like, shitty mechanism, like, you know, racism or patriarchy or, like, class or mental health, whatever, capitalistic, like, capitalism-induced mania, right?
Like, it's better, it's easier for me to cope with life when I can domesticate it within its sphere.
Right.
I'll tell you, though, speaking from experience, it's actually easier to cope with life when you just totally divest from it.
Yeah.
You see, like, that's a thing that happened.
I have no idea what it is.
Like, I really, I have no idea what it was.
But I don't even care to try to do the labor of figuring out what it was.
Like, I get what you're saying, which is, like, this disturbing moment happened, and hooking it to a narrative allows me some comfort because I know where it fits.
But it's even more comforting to be, like, I have no idea where it fits.
Like, that was just an alien experience that happened, and it's still alien, and it stays alien.
But leaving it back, like, you know, the slap is the text, right?
There can be the desire to try to close the book on it, to find its proper context, to domesticate it, or even just to say that it happened.
Now the question is, like, but, you know, if we're going to follow the lines that we've been setting out here, it's, like, how does the text become a source of provocation?
Like, you know, not just in its effect, because it's clearly been a source of provocation, but what it has provoked is a whole lot of attempts at closing the narrative.
So, like, I'll see you next time.